though Egbert set up a face-recognition
coffee maker that dispenses a cup of
coffee when it detects a person Yannick
and Celeste Joule L as a new beer from
dogfish Head brewery that is steeped
with lunar meteorites received from a
company that makes NASA space suits and
once it's gone it's gone forever
Vsauce Kevin here this is mine
researchers now say that the hemispheres
of Albert Einstein's brain were
unusually well connected and that could
have contributed to his brilliance after
his death in 1955 Einstein's son allowed
the Nobel prize-winning physicist brain
to be studied and while last year it was
noted that he had a dramatically
expanded prefrontal cortex a new
technique to study the corpus callosum
developed by Weiwei men of East China
Normal University's Department of
Physics found Einstein had more
extensive connections between certain
parts of his cerebral hemispheres
compared to 15 samples of elderly men
and 52 men Einsteins age in 1905 arc
nova is an inflatable concert hall
created by architect Arata Isozaki and
sculptor Anish Kapoor the sculpture
takes about two hours to inflate and
holds around 500 people the arc was made
to tour the areas of Tohoku that were
devastated by the earthquake and tsunami
in 2011 and they're looking to bring
back hope and encouragement to the
cities via music design and culture
blizzardon is a 3d printed personalized
toothbrush that thoroughly cleans your
teeth as you grind and bite down on it
in just six seconds Hana yakiniku wants
your smartphone to smell like food by
attaching the device you can pick the
food you want and then smell it while
eating something plain like white rice
or lettuce it's supposed to work well
for people on a budget or on a diet and
comes in many different scents including
coffee coconut curry and cinnamon roll
hawks Ocean Technologies has created the
deep flight super falcon a kind of
underwater plane it has the ability to
do barrel rolls and jump out of the
water because of its wings making it
more like an underwater plane than a
typical submarine their commitment to
using electric energy makes it safe to
operate around human
marine life and they're taking orders
for them right now
mollusks have teeth made of magnetite
which is the hardest material made by a
living organism ever so yah yah Sakawa
electric is making a device to help
people who have suffered from a stroke
to be able to walk more easily it's
similar to the boot that stroke victims
currently use but it's now motorized to
help lift and move the user's leg
forward giving them a longer and more
confidence try a sensor inside the boot
to text when the user is walking and
starts to automatically assist allowing
them to take bigger steps and they're
hoping to make this commercially
available by 2015 the Pico bruise I'm
addict is a world's first all grain
in-home beer brewing system it's
essentially an espresso maker for beer
all you have to do is load up your hops
and barley choose the kind of beer you
want press go and let it do its thing
within a couple of hours the beer is
made and all of the data is sent to your
computer so you can save your favorite
recipes meanwhile monsura is a robotic
bartender that learns its users tastes
and customizes the drinks depending on
each person using a touchscreen you can
browse through the cocktails and once
you pick a drink you can choose its
strength whether you want normal light
weight or boss it even emails a grocery
list to your local liquor store and
schedules a delivery when you're running
low on ingredients the Pinocchio lizard
is back thought to be extinct for the
last 50 years it was recently observed
by tropical herping in Ecuador
engineering students at Rice made this
robotic arm for a teenager named Dee who
suffers from a brittle bone disease the
project lasted two years and resulted in
this cool robotic arm that gives Dee the
ability to safely pick things up and
become more independent just in time for
him to start college split are the
world's first stand-alone audio player
with no cables doesn't require bluetooth
it's completely hands-free and you can
adjust the volume and change tracks by
using byte clicks but you can also lock
them so you can bite without altering
the music finally collide elapsed from
my labs is a beautiful video of
different time-lapse shots with the
Kaleidoscope effect
you
I'm gonna leave you with self-assembling
robot cubes and as always thanks for
watching